ok let's get into audience questions for
the week there's a lot you can tell
we're getting close to this November
election and we are we're only about
four months away now because a lot of
the questions coming in from you guys
are about the November election the
first question is about polling and it's
about specifically comparing polling
right now to polling in 2016 the
question is David how does Biden's lead
against Trump today differ from
Hillary's lead against Trump in 2016 or
is this going to be a repeat of 2016 all
over again
where Trump wins by a small margin in a
few states
excellent question the first answer is
we really don't know until people vote
which means every single one of you
should be imagining my vote could
determine whether Trump wins my state or
whether Biden wins my state and you
should go vote on that basis that's
number one now let's look at the actual
polls and look at differences between
Hillary's lead in 2016 and Trump's lead
in 2020 and Biden's lead in 2020
Hillary's popular vote lead in 2016 at
the time of the election was smaller
than Biden's is today we've talked
before about how it can happen that you
lose the popular vote by a lot and win
electoral II that can happen you can
draw these maps where I think I saw one
over the weekend where you could have
22% of the popular vote and still win
the electoral college just because you
can make that scenario on a map doesn't
mean it's likely and so one of the big
differences between 2016 and 2020 is
that right now Biden's popular vote lead
is bigger than Hillary's was on election
day that can change the second important
difference between 2016 and 2020 is that
when you look at some of the states that
are likely to be the key states the
margin for Biden right now is far bigger
a Hillary in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
and Michigan for example in 2016 you
look at
Michigan numbers right now they're
insane
so does that tell us they couldn't
change between now and November of
course they could change what it tells
us as the polls would have to change far
more dramatically than we've typically
seen them change in the last four months
and or the polls would need to be way
more wrong this year than they've been
in years past that's good for Joe Biden
the other sort of number two point two
is that Joe Biden is over 50% and well
over 50% nationally in a lot of polls
where is at this point in 2016 Hillary
Clinton was hitting 50 in some polls and
when she did it was usually like 50
maybe 51 Joe Biden has regularly been
hitting 50% in polls and the reason that
that's extra important right now is two
reasons one if Biden's already at 50 in
an important state for example he
doesn't need to worry about the
undecideds and the third party's I mean
yes he still wants to try to get them
but the point is he as long as he
retains the people he currently has can
win those states even if against an
incumbent as you get closer and closer
to Election Day more of the undecideds
might break for the incumbent in this
case Donald Trump so the 50% threshold
is also important and then that's the
last thing this incumbency factor 2016
was two challengers against each other
with an outgoing president now you could
make the case with an outgoing
Democratic president Barack Obama that
is a help for the Democratic candidate
Hillary Clinton okay that's not a factor
right now this is challenger versus
incumbent now in many ways the power of
incumbency does suggest the undecideds
as we get closer to November maybe some
third-party people maybe some people who
like Trump but aren't necessarily
thinking of voting might decide to vote
usually incumbency helps you as you get
closer to Election Day the concerning
number if you're Trump
is that as an incumbent in some polls
he's in the mid to high 30s that's very
very bad and that that as an incumbent
is a greater red flag then if this was
challenger against challenger you look
at Trump's high disapproval and he sort
of got an entire picture so in hearing
me talk about all of this
what should you take away from it
nothing absolutely nothing
you should be imagining I could turn my
state from Trump to Biden if I don't
vote that could be the vote that gives
my state to Trump if I do vote my vote
could be the vote that gives it to bite
now rarely is it actually a one vote
difference but the point is a lot of us
have these thoughts if all of us who
have these thoughts decided to stay home
Trump wins and that's the the most
important takeaway that I can imagine
hopefully we will all make the right
decisions in November and hopefully
November 4th will be you know it doesn't
have to be the big progressive victory
that we would all like it would still be
a major major improvement in the United
States and I hope to be there with you
when it happens